et au plateau qui se trouve à hawaï dans
l'hémicycle et science est en train de
se faire et donc eh bien on devrait
avoir un instant à l'autre la cloche qui
retentit et le début de cette séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
ouais
c'est oms a été distribué nous n'avons
pas reçu d'observation il y en a t'il en
séance
je n'en vois point le procès verbal est
adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement notre séance
et retransmise en direct sur public
sénat ne peut site internet
chacun sera attentif à observer au cours
de nos échanges d'une des valeurs
essentielles du sénat qui est le respect
des uns et des autres et on vous
remerciant mes chers collègues d'avoir
été très nombreux à la cérémonie aux
plaques aux fonctionnaires du sénat et
au sénateur mort pour la france je
voulais vous dire que naturellement
cette journée se situe aussi dans ce
temps de mémoire collective que nous
allons vivre demain 11 novembre la
parole est qu à notre collègue cécile
kuperman pour le groupe communiste
républicain
citoyen et écologistes avaient la parole
ma chère collègue monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues selon l'association de
consommateurs ufc que choisir un foyer
qui s'attendait à payer 1000 30 euros
d'électricité pour l'année en janvier
2021 devra finalement s'acquitter d'une
facture de 1400 euros les 100 euros de
chaque énergie ne suffiront pas ni pour
les plus pauvres ni pour tous les autres
c'est une baisse substantielle du
pouvoir d'achat à laquelle se rajoute la
hausse continue depuis plusieurs
semaines du prix des carburants pour
autant rien n'est prévu dans le projet
de loi de finances pour faire contribuer
les grands groupes pétroliers les
acteurs de l'énergie au financement et
ainsi baisser réellement et pour tous
nos concitoyens
le coût de l'énergie
comptez vous réellement ne pas mettre à
contribution ses grands groupes pour
l'effort de solidarité
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre déléguée en charge de
l'industrie madame pas dire une et chez
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice que kerman
jeu peut-être remettre en perspective
cette question du pouvoir d'achat
puisque il est intéressant de voir ce
qui a été accompli sous cette mandature
par ce gouvernement le pouvoir d'achat
beaucoup plus progresser sous cette
mandature que sous les déos précédente
mandature d'abord parce que nous avons
créé de l'emploi plus de cinq cent mille
emplois ensuite parce que nous nous
sommes employés à faire en sorte que
chacun de ces emplois permettent à
chacun de vivre plus dignement et je
rappel l'augmentation de la prime
d'activité pour 4,4 millions de foyers
la suppression des cotisations chômage
et maladie pour 29 millions d'actifs
la baisse des impôts notamment la taxe
d'habitation et l'impôt sur le revenu
des personnes physiques la
revalorisation des professionnels de
santé des fonctionnaires mais moins bien
mieux rémunérés ce sont des actions
concrètes au service des français et de
leur pouvoir d'achat vous m'interrogez
sur le coût de l'énergie et vous savez
que nous avons agi pour faire en sorte
que ce coût de l'énergie rock - les
personnes les plus vulnérables
je me permets de rappeler l'engagement
du premier ministre sur ce banc pour
précisément faire en sorte que nous
ayons un bouclier sur l'augmentation du
gaz sur l'augmentation de l'électricité
et que nous permet de nous puissions
déployés dès décembre sur une grande
partie des français qui en bénéficieront
je vous rappelle que ses 38 millions de
bénéficiaires 100 euros dogo de
l'augmentation du chèque énergie qui
s'ajoute aux 150 euros déjà existants je
voudrais ajouter une chose lorsqu'on
investit dans les énergies bas carbone
lorsqu'on investit dans le dans les
énergies renouvelables et dans l'énergie
nucléaire c'est comme ça que nous
accompagnons les français pour avoir
accès durablement et une énergie à bas
coûts lorsque nous menons le combat de
la décarbonation et que nous permettons
à 450 mille fois lié de rénover
techniquement leur maison 2 justement
moins payés en coûts de chauffage c'est
comme ça que nous accompagnons aussi sur
le long terme le combat du pouvoir
d'achat un piqûre mode
madame la ministre total energy annonce
un bénéfice net multiplié par 23 au
troisième trimestre et vous êtes dans
l'autosatisfaction com ou nous avons
écouté un président devenu candidat hier
soir il n'a pratiquement pas aborder la
première préoccupation des français le
pouvoir d'achat mais al'inverse
stigmatisation détestable des chômeurs
une vieille formule ressorti travailler
plus et plus longtemps mais silence
total sur la hausse des salaires la
hausse des pensions la hausse des
retraites c'est pour ça de pourtant de
cela dont les français ont besoin
l'échec très l'hecto ne compense en rien
la hausse de l'énergie et la hausse du
carburant il y a urgence à offrir dès à
présent aux françaises et aux français
les moyens de vivre dignement de leur
travail il faut sortir de cette spirale
qui plonge jour après jour de plus en
plus de nos concitoyens dans la
précarité ces femmes ces hommes ne sont
pas les coupables des difficultés de
notre pays ils en sont aujourd'hui les
premières victimes
la valeur travail madame la ministre ne
se décrète pas elle s'incarne par
l'ouverture immédiate de négociations
pour la revalorisation du smic des
salaires et des pensions de retraite
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue didier
rambaud pour le gros du rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant
si monsieur le président ma question
concerne les services publics de
proximité madame la ministre 75 % des
français sont attachés au service public
de proximité selon une récente étude de
l'ifop il ya deux jours l'assemblée
nationale a approuvé le versement chaque
année de 500 à 520 millions d'euros au
bénéfice du groupe la poste dans le
cadre l'examen du projet de loi de
finances pour 2022 préserver la mission
historique de service public attribuées
à la poste malgré un déficit conséquent
liés à la baisse structurelle des
volumes et aux conséquences de la crise
sanitaire l'état l'avait promis et la
promesse sera tenue nos collègues
sénateurs patrick chaize pierre louault
et rémy chardon avait estimé dans leur
rapport sénatorial qu'une dotation
budgétaire étaient nécessaires pour que
la poste continue assurer un service
postal universel sur tout le territoire
mes chers collègues ces dotations nous
l'avons madame la ministre nous saluons
le respect de cet engagement le
gouvernement réaffirme son action perdre
de crise avec deux priorités soutenir
notre économie est préservée des
services publics de proximité auquel les
français sont attachés toutefois des
attentes des interrogations des
inquiétudes demeurent elles sont
nombreuses parfois excessive mais
souvent légitimes la peur du délitement
et de l'éloignement des services publics
est une réalité nous pouvons la nier
face à ces craintes comment maintenir
des services publics de proximité et de
qualité dans notre pays et plus
particulièrement dans les territoires
ruraux vous savez madame la ministre les
attentes de nos soutiens concitoyens
sont fortes nous devons poursuivre nos
efforts pour répondre au sentiment
d'abandon ou de déclassement qui
contribuent à la crise de confiance
entre les citoyens et les élus
pour vous répondre la parole et yodelice
la transformation et de la fonction
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur rambo maintenir des services
publics de qualité et de proximité c'est
une des priorités que depuis 2010 est le
président république et son gouvernement
mène c'était évidemment une priorité de
du ministère de la transformation et la
fonction publique y est le mien et je
peux vous dire que nous menons une
action tout à fait concrète et tangible
pour que partout sur le territoire pour
que tous les français est un accès aux
services publics qui répondent à leurs
besoins la première mesure est surtout
aujourd'hui résultats que nous avons
c'est franc services comme vous savez
piloter par jacqueline gourault qui
permettent aujourd'hui dans 1500 lieu en
france dans des bus dans l'ensemble du
territoire les français ont tous à moins
de 30 minutes de chez eux un lieu unique
avec les neuf services publics de leur
quotidien les retraites l'assurance
maladie pôle emploi les allocations
familiales et dans ce cas de la poste et
vous l'avez rappelé en est un partenaire
important comme vous le savez dans votre
département c'est déjà à 15 espace rend
service objectif est de doubler ce
maillage et nous y mettons des moyens
avec jacqueline gourault et des élus
pour y parvenir mais je veux dire
quelque chose évidemment l'humain c'est
essentiel à proximité c'est essentiel
mais ça ne s'oppose pas au numérique
quand j'entends des candidats à la
présidentielle nous dire que le
numérique serait contraire à l'accès aux
services publics je ne peux pas laisser
dire ça puisque la majorité des français
demandent aussi des services publics
d'eux qu'ils soient accessibles à chacun
par le numérique des personnes en
situation de handicap des personnes dans
les territoires ruraux qui va les
services publics qui ne soit pas
dépendants des horaires dépendant la
distance et donc oui le numérique est
aussi évidemment un investissement que
nous faisons fortement notamment le cas
du plan de relance et comme vous le
voyez notre combat c'est pas le
numérique pour le numérique c'est pas la
proximité uniquement c'est que chacun
trouve ce qui correspond à ses besoins
et que nous ayons ainsi toujours une
alternative j'ai demandé qu'à chaque
fois qu'une démarche est en ligne elle
souhaite aussi accessibles soit par
téléphone soit de manière physique je
crois que politiquement il faut qu'on
soit aujourd'hui responsable le but
c'est que chaque français là où il est
est un mac c'est un service public qui
correspond à ses besoins que nous
arrêtions d'opposer les france entre eux
entre les ruraux les ruraux et les
urbains et que ce service public sont
accessibles à tous partout sous toutes
ses formes
d'abord l'état notre collègue bernard
jomier pour les rouges socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues je
voudrait interroger le gouvernement qui
nous apporte quelques précisions suite
aux déclarations du chef de l'état hier
soir sur la crise sanitaire le chef de
l'état indiqué que la poursuite de la
délivrance du pass and it erp serait
conditionnée pour les personnes de plus
de 65 ans à l'administration d'une dose
de rappel d'ailleurs il me semble que
c'est la première fois qu'une borne
d'âge est posée est ce que première
question cette mesure va être étendu à
l'ensemble de la population éligible au
vaccin deuxième question si le pass
sanitaires et comme cela semble l'outil
qui permet de maintenir une protection
collective élevé par la vaccination dans
votre stratégie alors à quelles
conditions
estimez vous que le pass sanitaires
pourraient être levés je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et collèges
les solidarités de fonte et monsieur v
en
monsieur le mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur
pourquoi cela
vous n'étiez pas là ma chichi paix à
longvic vous étiez peut-être pas là mais
j'étais là hier soir à 11 heures du soir
j'étais là avant-hier aussi au sénat
peut-être que certains d'entre vous
n'étaient pas là donc ils ne vont pas
aperçu rassurez vous je suis au sénat
toutes les semaines et un certain nombre
d'heures on peut regarder si vous voulez
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bernard jomier vous
posez vous poser une question sur
l'extension du passé l'été à d'abord
vous dire qu'il ya de cohérence au moins
à ce que on propose cette vaccination en
priorité aux 65 ans et plus et désormais
bientôt aux 50 ans et plus vous le savez
pas ce que vous êtes médecin mais le
système immunitaire est plus fragile
quand on prend un peu de l'âge et donc
le système immunitaire a besoin d'avoir
des rappels de vaccination c'est le cas
pour le coc vide c'est le cas pour
d'autres virus qu'on connaît bien pour
pouvoir réactiver le système immunitaire
pour vérifier qu'on est bien le même
niveau de protection la même capacité à
synthétiser des anticorps le moment où
on est confrontés à un virus pourquoi la
logique qui passe d'abord nous avons
laissé du temps aux personnes âgées de
65 ans et plus pour se faire vacciner
les trois quarts d'entre elles
d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient éligibles sont
d'ores et déjà d'ores et déjà reçu une
dose de rappel qui est un très bon
chiffre mais ça veut dire qu'il en reste
encore et c'est surtout la logique du
paas le passe à lithaire c'est quoi
c'est que lorsque vous rentrez dans un
lieu public avec du monde notamment un
lieu fermé vous avez un moindre risque
d'être contaminé vous-même et de
contaminer les autres donc si on
considère qu'au bout d'un moment la
protection conférée par le vaccin est
moins importante il est logique du coup
de restreindre l'accès aux facilités a
donc c'est pourquoi le président de la
république a lancé cet appel de la même
manière on est en train de descendre
progressivement en âge sur le rappel de
la vaccination à mesure d'ailleurs qu'on
avait commencé la vaccination
souvenez-vous chez les personnes les
plus âgées et ensuite par tranche d'âge
nous avons des retours sur la population
âgée de 65 ans et plus nous avons des
retours sur la population de 50 ans et
plus les populations plus jeunes ont été
vaccinées plus tard dans notre pays et
ailleurs dans le monde donc nous n'avons
pas encore le retour sur l'évolution
d'immunité est ce que les scientifiques
nous disent et que peut-être dans
quelques mois nous verrons qu'il sera
nécessaire de proposer un rappel de
vaccination plus large en tous les cas
nous agissons en fonction des données
scientifiques pour protéger les français
quant à la question de savoir à quand le
la suppression du pass sanitaires et
bien aujourd'hui nous faisons face à une
recrudescence de l'épidémie s'est
certainement pas le moment de se poser
la question
jugée au mieux
monsieur le ministre je comprends bien
donc nous allons vers des rappels pour
l'ensemble de la population et que la
délivrance du pass and i ter sera
conditionnée à ses rappels donc vous
tracer une perspective où à l'horizon
d'un an deux ans trois ans le pass
sanitaires se poursuivra peut-être alors
moi je voudrais vous dire que nous
portons l'idée que la vie en société
impose des obligations et il savait en
l'occurrence la vaccination mais nous
avons le sentiment qu'avec cet outil du
pass sanitaires vous êtes en train de
changer de paradigme sur la question du
contrôle car de fait vous utilisez un
outil que vous étendez sans qu'on n'en
perçoivent bien les limites et vous
étendez le champ des contrôles
systématiques en lieu et place des
contrôles aléatoires et a posteriori qui
dans une société démocratique et de
liberté sont les plus répandus et c'est
là que se situe une interrogation
profonde pour les parlementaires que
nous sommes attachés aux libertés
publiques et avec regret je constate
d'ailleurs que le conseil
constitutionnel ne nous apporte pas d'
analyse qui soit très contributif sur ce
point
si la parole et
andré guiol pour le gros du
rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'état chargé de la
biodiversité
bérengère à bas madame la ministre nous
ne savons plus à quel saint se vouer en
effet cette année la production de miel
en france s'avère deux fois inférieure à
celle de l'année dernière une année
pourtant déjà sur le déclin les causes
sont forcément multiples météorologiques
dérèglement climatique emploi de
pesticides
malgré les immenses efforts des uns de
nos agriculteurs
91,6 toutes participé à la perte de la
richesse et de la biodiversité
ce phénomène ne serait pas plus alarmant
que les autres signaux de ce déclin si
elle veut rester nous n'avait pas prédit
que la fin des abeilles véritables
indicateurs biologiques anneaux serait
probablement la fin de l'humanité
l'union européenne a eu l'intelligence
dans devant la baisse de population
d'abeilles en attendant d'en connaître
les causes de ce phénomène d'accompagner
la création de l'observatoire français
david au logis amazon dans le var proche
de vos villages de néoules en provence
verte cet observatoire est chargé de
sélectionner des espèces d'abeilles plus
résistantes dans l'atteinte de
l'environnement - recife pour elle est
donc pour nous très prochainement doré
paraître un arrêté abeilles pour lequel
les désaccords relatif à l'encadrement
des oeuvres d'autorisation dépannage se
font le jour mettant en lumière la
nécessité de trouver un équilibre entre
une apiculture soucieuse une agriculture
vertueuse une agriculture pour laquelle
nous avons dû dans la douleur
réintroduire l'emploi de néonicotinoïdes
pour aider notamment les agriculteurs à
maintenir le rendement betteraviers
victime d'une industrie sucrière
toujours plus exigeante et spéculative
ma question madame la ministre quel sera
le poids de la biodiversité que vous
défendez dans les arbitrages et la
rédaction de cet article abbey de cet
arrêté avait car après l'emploi massif
dans le passé de produits tueur des
sectes pollinisateurs nous saluons bien
que nous allions dans la mauvaise
direction aujourd'hui avec trop de
souplesse donné alors et emploi de nom
de nous n'ont pas l'impression de
reculer dans la bonne je vous remercie
pour la parole quand même un chef d'état
en charge de la biodiversité vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gueule vous nous
interpeller effectivement sur cette
mortalité anormalement élevé des
abeilles qui est scientifiquement établi
et nous avons donc effectivement cette
cette vigilance accrue cette nécessité à
enrayer ce déclin des pollinisateurs en
plus largement puisque ils sont plus
largement concerné que les abeilles ils
sont indispensables pour notre
agriculture 70% des cultures dépendent
de la pollinisation ce qui permet la
fécondation vous le savez donc une
question de souveraineté alimentaire ce
n'est qu'une question de préservation
évidente de la biodiversité nous y
sommes donc très très attaché et très
mobilisés dans ce contexte avec un plan
pollinisateurs que vous savez qui a été
annoncé en août 2020 et afin d'enrayer
cette ce déclin ce plan il est plus
large que l'arrêté que vous avez
mentionné il doit englober à la fois les
résultats des concertations des
consultations et des concertations qui
ont été très large sur ce sur ce sujet
comprendre l'origine du déclin des
pollinisateurs c'est un des premiers
leviers encourager les bonnes pratiques
les faire connaître la ou des
initiatives ont montré leur leurs fruits
et sont extrêmement prometteuse
associés par exemple des réflexions sur
la plantation des ressources mellifères
les fauche tardive et toutes ces bonnes
pratiques qui doivent être généralisées
adapter la réglementation évidemment en
matière d'utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques vous l'avez dit et
puis améliorer la santé des ruches en ce
qui concerne plus particulièrement la
révision de l'arrêté elle se précise sur
les modalités d'épandage en période de
floraison soit dans quelques jours ou
quelques semaines par an selon les
cultures avec des abeilles qui butinent
et sont à ce moment là particulièrement
exposés et on sait que les produits
formulés phytopharmaceutiques font
partie des facteurs de risque pour ces
pollinisateurs qu'il soit d'ailleurs
sauvages ou domestiques avec donc deux
princes yp deux principes évident
d'abord évaluer le risque est protégée
sans jamais laisser les agriculteurs
sans solution il nous faut des réponses
des réponses adaptées à chaque situation
et puis une méthode celle de la
concertation on l'a dit celle de
l'éclairage scientifique et le réel nous
baser sur l'expérience le vécu
l'expérience de deux terrains notamment
des agriculteurs ceci pour éviter au
maximum les traitements en protégeant
les abeilles tout en respectant le
travail des agriculteurs
nous y serons très vigilants et nous
aurons le plaisir de vous présenter et
de sortir le plan et l'arrêté du même
nom dans les semaines qui viennent jour
merci
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
guillaume bompard pour le groupe
écologie solidarité et territoires
monsieur le président vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre le monde
est face à son destin la pandémie n'est
pas terminée faute d'avoir ouvert les
brevets des vaccins et de jouer la
solidarité mondiale le virus continue de
circuler de nous menacer l'avenir de
l'humanité notre capacité à préserver
une planète habitable pour l'espace pour
l'espèce humaine se joue en ce moment
même à glasgow dans ce contexte alors
que plus que jamais nous devons imaginer
le monde solidaire et coopératif d'après
la france s'apprête à prendre la
présidence de l'union européenne c'est
le moment légitime que choisit le
président de la république pour
s'adresser à la nation
vingt-sept minutes de discours 27
minutes pour dessiner non pas le monde
de demain mais le monde d'hier voire
d'avant-hier le travail invoqué comme un
mantra et son corollaire de
stigmatisation de toutes celles et ceux
qui en sont exclus la croissance le
productivisme le nucléaire tous ces
étendards des trente glorieuses sonne si
faux dans la bouche d'un homme qui n'a
pourtant connu que la crise structurelle
d'un capitalisme incompatible avec la
préservation du vivant et la justice
sociale un autosatisfecit
des rangs sur l'investissement en faveur
de la santé quand l'hôpital a perdu 5700
lit au milieu de la pandémie comme sur
la pauvreté alors que la misère
s'intensifie toujours face au concours
lépine des mesures inepte et injuste des
candidats aient l'air lundi soir sur lci
emmanuel macron est venu rappeler à tous
ceux qui voudraient oublier que la
droite c'est lui alors monsieur le
premier ministre si le président et
candidat au lieu de mener le navire
france dans la tempête qui le disent et
qu'ils cessent d'utiliser les moyens de
l'état et le prestige de la fonction
pour faire campagne
réponse à monsieur le premier ministre
je vais la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président grootaers c'est
pas très bien si c'est une question
éléments programmatiques que vous avez
abordé là je vais quand même tenté de
vous répondre monsieur le président
notamment par rapport à l'intervention
du président de la république hier soir
qui est effectivement intervenu un
moment important après un celles qui
l'avaient fait le 12 juillet et qui vise
notamment à fixer la feuille de route du
gouvernement que je dirige pour les
semaines et les mois à venir compte tenu
de ce qu'est la situation du pays du
monde vous l'avait dit et des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens je ne
partage évidemment pas vous n'en serez
pas surpris monsieur le président ni
votre diagnostic ni vos appréciations
simplement je rappelle au sénat que les
sujets qui ont été abordés par le chef
de l'état sait vous l'avez dit vous-même
évidemment d'abord notre mobilisation
notre vigilance face à la reprise
épidémique qui vous le savez ne concerne
pas que la france avec un certain nombre
de dispositions annoncées par le chef de
l'état avec un petit rappel que vous
savez mais que je fais c'est une
pandémie de mondiale et il faut
effectivement lutter contre la pandémie
dans toutes les parties du monde et la
france après les états unis et le
deuxième pays c'est le mechanics me
kovacs a donné des doses
aux pays qui n'ont pas les moyens de les
payer et je pense que de cela nous
devons au moins tous être collectivement
fier deuxièmement deuxièmement mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs l'un des
sujets du moment les questions de
pouvoir d'achat et d'inflation ont été
abordés effectivement vous le savez
toutes et tous vous le voyez dans vos
départements sait les difficultés à
recruter là aussi on devrait se réjouir
de ce que la dynamique des créations
d'emplois grâce à la reprise grâce à la
relance grâce au plan de relance grâce à
la mobilisation de nos concitoyens est
parmi les plus forts d'europe
nous avons un des taux de chômage alors
que nous en annonçait l'explosion il ya
plusieurs mois parmi les plus bas depuis
15 ans mais ça ne suffit pas vous savez
de selon la banque de france c'est pas
moi qui dis y'a plus de 300000 emplois
qui ne sont pas pourvus aujourd'hui si
on l'est pour voyait on retombera au
taux de chômage de 1982 j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire oui c'est la
mobilisation générale pour faire face à
cette situation et non nous ne
stigmatisons personnes on ne peut pas
nous avons a reproché d'avoir suspendu
la réforme d'assurance chômage alors
même que le chômage monte et de veiller
à son entrée en vigueur ce sera pour
tous ces paramètres le 1er décembre
prochain alors que pour ces personnes
nous avons des emplois proposés c'est
pas stigmatiser que de dire ça c'est au
contraire leur proposer parce que nous
croyons à la valeur travail leur
proposer de s'élever par le travail
d'avoir un meilleur salaire et une
meilleure place dans la société alors
oui il faut faire entrer en vigueur
l'assurance chômage oui il faut que pôle
emploi multiplie les actions en
direction des entreprises et des
demandeurs d'emploi y compris nous
l'assumons les contrôles pour faire en
sorte que le travail encore le travail
et l'activité progresse dans notre
société
monsieur le président gontard
on l'a compris vous êtes satisfait
pourtant ne construira pas l'avenir avec
les lunettes du passé on une râpe en ut
rappaz contre le dérèglement climatique
sans changer de modèle on ne réduira pas
les inégalités en sachant sur les plus
démunis en s'acharnant sur les plus
démunis notre avenir sera écologique et
solidaire où il ne sera pas
même si la parole est à notre collègue à
la marque pour les groupes les
indépendants
république et territoires vous avez la
parole
de la ville j'annonce ici votre fonction
parce que je suis très étonné que la
ministre déléguée chargée de la ville
réponse à une question sur la d iter mes
chers collègues dans toute la france des
commissions d élue chargée d'allouer la
dotation pour équipement des territoires
la fameuse de terre au move ont commencé
leurs travaux pour l'air leur mission
consiste essentiellement à définir les
critères d'attribution des subventions
les décisions concernant les nouveaux
projets seront rendues en début d'année
prochaine en janvier ou en février selon
les cas pour un versement effectif en
mars 2022 nous le savons tous ici s'agit
d'un moment important pour les
collectivités territoriales et les élus
locaux l'attribution de la detr à de
puissants effets d'entraînement pour le
tissu des entreprises situées en
départements ruraux chaque année les
procédures d'attribution sont suivis de
près par les élus mais cette année le
contexte économique devrait donner une
tournure un peu particulière à ces
rendez vous et pour cause l'inflation
fait son grand retour nous en
connaissons les raisons macroéconomiques
avec la forte reprise en sortie de crise
la demande est forte et la pression
s'accroît sur les matières premières
l'énergie de façon très concrète cela se
traduit par une augmentation très forte
des coûts des projets les hypothèses sur
lesquelles les dossiers ont été bâties
préparée de longue date par les porteurs
de projets sont devenues caduques et les
plantes de financement risquent
fortement de déraper dans ce contexte
madame la ministre ma question est assez
simple alors que le sénat examinera tout
prochainement le projet de loi de
finances pour 2022 le gouvernement
envisage t-il de réviser l'enveloppé
globale de la detr pour prendre en
compte les effets de l'inflation plus
généralement au delà de ce dispositif
particulier quelles sont les réponses
que le gouvernement peut apporter aux
élus locaux qui règne de voir le budget
prévisionnel dérapé à cause de
l'inflation
pour répondre la parole est à madame la
ministre déléguée en charge
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur à la marque je suis
très étonné de vous voir surpris de vous
répondre sur une réforme qui a été porté
en 2005 par le ministre daubresse qui
porte sur la detr et la dsu et
aujourd'hui en tant que ministre de la
ville de rattacher à la mise la cohésion
des territoires je me fais un plaisir de
vous répondre et je voudrais vous dire
que je partage votre préoccupation
concernant les conséquences de
l'inflation sur les tons les coûts des
travaux publics c'est un sujet qui
concerne en premier chef les
collectivités qui arrive qui réalisent
la majeure partie de l'investissement
civile quelques éléments de contexte
d'abord là où ceux des prix a été
mesurée en 2020 puis 0 5% et redémarre
en 2021 et 2022 tiré par la hausse des
prix de l'énergie cependant cette hausse
ne se répercute pas forcément sur tous
les chantiers souvent le coût final
correspond aux devis signés entre les
maîtres d'ouvragé et l'entreprise
d'ailleurs les remontées des
collectivités locales sur ce sujet ne
sont à ce stade en tout cas ni massives
ni très fréquentes nous voyons bien
cependant que ce sujet sans doute devant
nous car des entreprises répercuteront
l'inflation et leurs devis qu'ils
proposeront aux collectivités en 2022
ensuite je voudrais vous donner quelques
éléments de réassurance d'abord l'état
continuera de soutenir l'investissement
local les plus de 2 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires de subvention de 2 tr de
décider de des pv en 2022 et comme vous
le savez il ya même une rallonge de
décile de plus de 300 millions d'euros
pour financer les certes eux qui a été
arbitrée par le premier ministre ainsi
que 95 millions d'euros supplémentaires
sur la ds eu et je crois que cela répond
à votre demande de crédit supplémentaire
pour venir en soutien aux collectivités
je note ensuite que l'inflation aura des
conséquences positives sur certaines
ressources fiscales des collectivités ce
qui leur permettra de faire face je
pense notamment aux impôts assis sur la
base locative cadastrale qui sont
revalorisées chaque année en tenant
compte de l' indice des prix les taux
d'actualisation de 2022 n'est pas encore
connue car il dépend des données de
novembre 2021 je pense aussi à la tva
qui dépend du prix des consommations et
en 2022 le hausse de la tva permettrait
pourra être de 5% et rapporter 400
millions d'euros aux intercommunalités
800 millions d'euros département et 800
millions aux régions bien entendu nous
continuerons à regarder la situation des
collectivités de près et le gouvernement
soutiendra les collectivités comme il
l'a toujours fait depuis 2017 et surtout
en ces temps troublés
monsieur marc
aurait point c'est à la fois de la déçu
de la detr vous savez nous les sénateurs
nous sommes des gens simples nous sommes
nous avons été des élus locaux nous
avons monté des projets on n'a pas
besoin de nous faire la leçon ici je
vous le dis vraiment franchement et nous
ce que nous souhaitons aujourd'hui que
nous constatons d augmentation très
significative de 20 30 40 et même 50%
pour une commune de chez moi eh bien
nous avons besoin que l'état soit en
dessous tient ici pour que nos communes
puissent réaliser effectivement les
projets je suis désolé on est des gens
simples on n'a pas besoin de nous
endormir avec crainte de avait la ds eu
la detr etc
on compte au gouvernement pour quelque
chose de supplémentaire
bush
la parole est un autre collègue jean
françois et son rapporteur général pour
le groupe est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le premier ministre
j'étais il ya quelques jours à l'elysée
ravi d'entendre le président de la
république appelait dans le cadre du
plan france 2030 à un élan de
réindustrialisation mais de la parole
aux actes il ya parfois un fossé je vais
illustrer concrètement
en meurthe-et-moselle à pont-à-mousson
saint gobain fleuron de l'industrie
française en matière de tuyaux d'eau en
fonte ductile
qui est qui emploie 2000 personnes qui
exporte plus de 50% de son chiffre
d'affaires et qui est leader européen
est victime d'une mauvaise nouvelle le
gouvernement apprend t-on se propose de
favoriser et de soutenir financièrement
l'implantation d'un concurrent indien se
positionnant exactement sur le même
marché dans le sud de la france
provoquant une colère légitime au regard
des efforts de l'entreprise qui mène des
travaux pour la décarbonation de sa
production et le maintien cette
production en france dans un marché je
le redis qui est en surcapacité et j'y
ajoute le non-respect de la réciprocité
normative puisque ce pays l'inde est
entièrement fermé aux exportations
monsieur le premier ministre confirmez
vous cette information là justifiez-vous
et surtout quelle est votre stratégie
pour parvenir à la nécessaire aînés
réindustrialisation de la france
pour vous répondre
parler comme ministre délégué en charge
de la mousserie on n'aime pas dire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs le sénateur monsieur le
rapporteur général us ont comme vous le
savez monsieur le rapporteur général et
d'ailleurs on a eu l'occasion et vous
avez l'occasion de rencontrer bruno le
maire sur ce sujet
depuis le début de ce quinquennat nous
avons été très attentifs au ministère de
l'économie et la situation de
pont-à-mousson vigilant sur le projet
industriel qui aurait pu changer la
trajectoire de ce site pour nous assurer
que ce site tombe pas en des mains qui
nous paraissait pas favorable d'un point
de vue industriel vigilant pour rendre
plus aisée et automatique les clauses
sociales et environnementales aux
acheteurs publics locaux qui leur
permettent de mieux prendre en compte la
valeur extra-financière des conduites en
fonte vendus par pont-à-mousson vigilant
donc en changeant la loi pour ça
vigilant en validant un soutien au titre
du plan de relance 2,5 millions d'euros
pour l'installation d'un four électrique
à pont-à-mousson qui sera le plus grand
d'europe ed qui s'agitent qui s'ajoutent
aux ensembles des actes dont bénéficie
saint gobain au titre du plan de relance
industrielle dix millions d'euros au
total et dans le cadre de la rénovation
thermique on peut penser que saint
gobain est un des principaux
bénéficiaires du plan de relance donc
croyez bien que nous sommes totalement
côté de cette entreprise qui a très
fortement profiter de l'accompagnement
industriels que nous avons donnée
vigilant enfin car nous avons un vrai
pour le maintien de droits antidumping
et compensatoires face à une concurrence
étrangère déloyale et c'est peut-être
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui ces acteurs qui
importent massivement et dont les
conduites sont achetés par des
collectivités locales cherchent à
s'implanter en europe alors de quoi est
il question d'avoir une entreprise qui
produit en france avec des salariés
français et des conditions de travail
social et environnemental française je
vous rassure c'est pas du tout la même
taille de conduite de deux comptes de
conduite fonte et s'étonne petit site de
200 salariés qui pourraient se créer de
l'autre côté de la frontière où qui peut
se créer en france voilà de quoi il est
question c'est un projet que nous
regardons avec raison est toujours
ennuyé en tête l'accompagnement de
pont-à-mousson mais je ne voudrais pas
que collectivement nous pensions que si
ce site s'installe en allemagne en
italie en espagne nous seront les
gagnants je remercie
monsieur jean-françois y sont
madame la ministre finalement vous avez
répondu à côté de la question parce que
vous évoquez vitaly mais il ya un site
qui a fermé en 2019 vous évoquez
l'allemagne bis repetita restructuration
fermeture d'un site
le marché français est en surcapacité de
50% comment vous comment voulez vous
faire comprendre que le gouvernement est
prêt à investir dans un marché en
surcapacité alors que vous avez une
entreprise vertueuses qui est soutenu
dans le cadre de france relance donc
nous vous demandons instamment avec mes
collègues sénateurs au premier rang
desquels ici notamment véronique guillot
taffin d'agbar de retirer le projet de
revoir la copie
cette proposition ce soutien du
gouvernement français est inacceptable
et in entendable à l'aube d'une campagne
présidentielle qui a été annoncé depuis
hier soir monsieur le premier ministre
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole que notre collègue sylvie
vermeillet pour le groupe entre et
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues un
sondage de la revue acteurs publics
vient de révéler que huit français sur
dix sont inquiets du niveau de la dette
publique
cantonné la dette qu'ovide ne suffit pas
à la rembourser je souhaite donc savoir
quelle est votre stratégie de
désendettement
hier soir le président de la république
s'est félicité d'avoir géré la crise
sanitaire en jeu site maîtrisant notre
déficit public il a ajouté que ce
déficit serait de -2 5% du pib cette
année or nous en étions à une prévision
de 8,1 pour cent du pib' auriez vous des
éléments dont nous ne disposons pas pour
l'étude du projet de loi de finances
pour 2022 dans ce cas le parlement
pourrait-il en être destinataire au lieu
de débattre de chiffres obsolète madame
la ministre les dépenses pour faire face
à la crise sanitaire était nécessaire et
nous les avons voté cautionnant ainsi
l'endettement généré mais il s'agit
maintenant de regarder l'avenir avec
lucidité c'est d'ailleurs avec cette
lucidité que nous avons essayé
d'envisager l'avenir de la dette
publique dans le rapport que nous avons
présentés tout à l'heure avec mon
collègue éric bocquet au nom de notre
délégation à la prospective
mais le plf 2022 et il lucide où est la
trajectoire vertueuse du budget que nous
devons à nos créanciers y at il des
chiffres que nous ne connaissons pas la
france connait tel le secret de l'argent
magique merci
pour vous répondre
la parole est à mme adam hadwin fut
ministre délégué en charge de
l'industrie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vermeille et comme vous l'avez très bien
dit nous avons effectivement au travers
des dispositifs qui ont permis de sauver
notre économie de sauver notre appareil
de production et de sauver nos salariés
fait en sorte de faire rebondir cette
économie cette politique et les eu un
coût ce coup il paye aujourd'hui puisque
nous avons la trajectoire de croissance
la plus élevée d'europe parce que nous
avons le taux de chômage le plus bas
depuis 15 ans et aucune personne dans
cet hémicycle
sincèrement aucune personne dans cet
hémicycle n'auraient imaginé être dans
cette situation il y à 18 mois je pense
que c'est important qu'on se le dise
collectivement et vous y avez contribué
et vous l'avez dit vous avez pris votre
responsabilité s'agissant de la
trajectoire de réduction des dépenses
publiques
nous avons annoncé dans le frr et vous
vous avez l'examiner je pense demain
sauf erreur de ma part avec olivier du
soft puisque jeu ou dans une semaine
enfin lancer dans quelques jours pardon
avec olivier du simple de vous en avez
les éléments il est très clair nous
avons un atterrissage valant tour de 8%
de déficit public en 2021 et nous visons
5% de déficit public en 2022 il n'y a
pas de magie dans ces chiffres ils sont
publics ils sont partagés avec vous et
vous allez être amené à vous prononcer
sur ces éléments sur la trajectoire dans
la durée vous savez que nous allons
mettre
spécifiquement 165 milliards d'euros de
dettes liées à l'accord vide pour les
amortir d'ici 2040 de par les fruits de
la croissance parce que ce que nous
avons sauvé l'année dernière avec nos
mesures pour les salariés
pour les entreprises va nous paraître va
nous permettre d'être sur un sentier de
croissance bien plus élevées et donc
d'en retirer les fruits pour rembourser
cet effort sur le temps long celle
avantage de l'état c'est sa
responsabilité
être capable de gérer des cris sur le
temps long et amortir ce que les acteurs
privés les ménages ne peuvent pas faire
madame
madame la ministre avec 1,9 milliard de
désendettement
l'année prochaine je ne vois pas comment
on éteint la dette qu vite d'ici 2040 de
première chose deuxième chose le fmi
vient d'exhorter la france à faire des
efforts et je crois qu'il a bien raison
si les taux d'intérêt remontent la
charge de la dette va être colossal il
s'agit donc d'établir des budgets
vertueux qui vont honorer la signature
de la france et puis nos sénateurs à la
veille du plf on apprécierait d'avoir
des chiffres plausible parce que je suis
sûr que vous ne pourrez pas vous passer
de notre sagesse merci
la parole comme
le président
ma question s'adresser à monsieur le
premier ministre et je remercie monsieur
le ministre de la santé de me répondre
même si le sujet me semble un peu loin
de ces préoccupations
encore que peut-être se sentira-t-il
concernés en effet monsieur le ministre
les jours passent et se ressemblent
chaque jour les annonces tombent
millions et milliards se succèdent si
bien qu'il nous faut désormais une
double page pour tout additionné plus 30
milliards pour le plan d'investissement
plus 2 milliards pour le contrat
d'engagement jeunes + 4 milliards pour
l'un des mythes et l'inflation plus 2
milliards pour renflouer france
compétences bref en moins de trois mois
plus de 25 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires pour la seule année 2000
22 annoncées au mépris de toutes les
institutions
chaque jour nous sommes interpellés
localement par les déplacements des
ministres avec un mélange des genres un
peu surprenant dernier exemple en date
en visite en savoie madame la secrétaire
d'état chargée de la jeunesse qui
échangea midi avec les missions locales
évoquent le contrat d'engagement
l'après-midi et lance le sort même la
nouvelle association jeunes majorité
présidentielle savoie avec emmanuel
macron chaque jour nous avons des états
généraux le plus récent celui de la
justice alors même que six textes ont
été portées par votre gouvernement et le
précédent sur ce thème
monsieur le ministre je pourrais être
plus longue mais je n'ai finalement
qu'une seule question est ce moral de
faire campagne avec l'argent des
français en creusant la dette
pour vous répondre
la parole et son ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement
[Applaudissements]
merci madame merci madame la sénatrice
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je vais répondre
à votre question qui aborde plusieurs
sujets qui au fond le sujet de la
politique et par menez qui est menée par
le gouvernement au fond vous nous dites
comment expliquer comment expliquer
simplement qu'un gouvernement jusqu'à la
dernière minute c'est l'engagement du
président de la république c'est
l'engagement du premier ministre mais la
politique qu'il entend mener qu'il a
annoncé depuis des années donc un
certain nombre de choses que vous voyez
un certain nombre de choses que vous
voyez se développer
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs un
certain nombre de choses que vous voyez
se développer sur les territoires ce
n'est rien d'autre que des ministres qui
font leur travail qui au plus près des
citoyens développe la politique et celle
du gouvernement vienne l'expliquer et
viennent rendre compte au fil aussi de
ce que nous nous ce que nous faisons
pardon et donc je suis assez étonné
après nous avoir parfois fait le
reproche et nous avoir expliqué que nous
n'étions pas assez sur le terrain que
désormais sur le terrain vous viognier
vous et vous émouvoir du fait de faire
notre mission donc madame la sénatrice
le gouvernement est à l'heure il sera à
l'oeuvre et je crois c'est ce
qu'attendent les français jusqu'à la
dernière minute et vous comptez vous
pouvez compter sur nous pour l'être
jusqu'à la dernière minute
madame plus haut
si monsieur le ministre pour votre
réponse finalement je n'en attendais pas
d'autre parce que dans cet hémicycle
mais même au sein du gouvernement chacun
le sait chaque jour et j'allais dire
maintenant chaque soir parce que nous
avons tous écouté le président de la
république hier écoutant et attendant un
discours sur le cola co lead et finale
en ayant un discours de campagne
présidentielle chaque jour 5 soir
emmanuel macron achète son élection
[Applaudissements]
la parole est qu à notre collègue
catherine conconne pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
monsieur le président madame la ministre
les prix de l'énergie flotte dans ladite
outre-mer plus 20 pouces en menant les
sens plus cher le gaz plus cher alors
attention toutes les révoltes sociales
dans ladite outre-mer notamment celle de
2009 sont ni de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie je vous appelle donc un gig
dès maintenant à ne pas attendre
l'explosion je suis consciente que
l'ongle d'attac ne saurait être la
fiscalité les taxes et à son nul celle
des collectivités plus que raisonnable
côté brut on connaît les conditions du
marché j'aime bien ce mot d'attirer
votre attention sur d'autres composantes
de la fixation des prix qui sont manquer
totalement de transparence arrêtons nous
un instant sur l'exemple du très
emblématique gaz utilisé par de nombreux
foyers plus de dix mille tonnes
consommées l'an dernier par exemple sur
notre île en deux ans le prix du bidon a
augmenté de 50% sur le montant de 32
euros la moitié soit 16 euros ou à
présent des coûts de distribution
si lapin de transport et du revendeur de
100 produits semble légitime un peu plus
de 4 go comment désormais se décompose
les douze heureux restant seul est
presque 32 du prix global qui les munir
t-il sur quelle base on l'ignorent on la
sait si peu il y à une union chances de
transparence il existe un sentiment
d'injustice
qualifié de profitations en créole et
qui perdure non nos populations ne
peuvent pas être toujours plus pauvres
et payer toujours plus cher ce n'est pas
acceptable oui il ya eu le chèque
énergie c'est un soulagement ponctuel
mais ce n'est pas la solution madame la
ministre elle vous prête à lancer
courageusement cette nécessaire mission
transparence très attendu afin de
soulager les ultramarins face à la
flambée des prix l'état est il prêt à
ont fait fait à la place pharos je sais
rémunération d'intermédiaires et ses
marges qui sont frappés d'opacité
pour vous répondre
la parole est à la secrétaire d'état en
charge de la biodiversité
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice conconne nous entendons votre
sentiment votre émotion qui est palpable
face à cette réalité d'une précarité
énergétique auquel nous faisons tous
face à cette émotion nous répondons des
actions concrètes vous le savez d'abord
dans des mesures d'urgence qui doivent
agir sur le budget des ménages avec ce
chèque énergie exceptionnelle de 100
euros pour 5,8 millions de ménages déjà
bénéficiaire du chèque énergie et en
outre-mer cela représentera plus de 280
mille foyers ce nouveau chèque il sera
envoyé 100 démarches supplémentaires
c'est donc tout à fait automatisés il
est déjà possible d'acheter des
bouteilles de gaz avec le chèque énergie
vous l'avait dit et cette mesure cette
possibilité elle sera renforcée en
incitant les fournisseurs à se faire
agréer pour mettre en place si
nécessaire des systèmes d'avoir quand le
chèque ne serait pas totalement
consommée ensuite une indemnité
inflation 200 euros va être distribuée
vous le savez notamment pour faire face
à cette hausse des prix du carburant il
s'agit clairement de la meilleure
solution parce que vous l'avez dit une
bêtise une baisse des taxes sur les
carburants outre-mer n'aurait pas pas
d'intérêt ni d'impact cette indemnité
elle concernera environ 38 millions de
nos concitoyens qui gagnent moins de
2000 euros nets par mois et près d'un
million d'ultramarins en seront
destinataires et puis ils seront tous
concernés ceux qui travaillent ceux qui
sont la recherche d'un emploi les
retraités des personnes bénéficiaires
des minima sociaux ces mesures elle
s'applique donc vraiment comme des
mesures de justice sociale et de lutte
dans cette précarité énergétique
bien entendu nous veillons nous veillons
à ce que l'application stricte de la
formule de calcul des prix réglementés
des carburants empêche toute marche d un
dieu et nous avons également mis en
place vous le savez le bouclier
tarifaire sur notamment le gaz de ville
électricité avec une hausse de
l'électricité qui sera plafonné à 4 %
une mesure qui bénéficie à tous les
droits mais wallis et futuna ainsi que
trois saints ce bouclier il sera mis en
place par une baisse de la taxe sur la
consommation d'électricité qui
bénéficiera également aux entreprises il
y a donc une totale transparence les
tarifs réglementés de vente du gaz de
ville sont aussi gelé jusqu'à fin 2022
le coût de ce bouclier tarifaire au
couple il est 5 milliards le chèque
énergie représente 600 millions d'euros
la prime inflation 3,8 milliards ce sont
quelques 10 milliards d'aidé qui doivent
lutter dans ses qualités énergétiques je
remercie
la parole qu'à notre collègue florence
lassarade
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
le gouvernement a prétendu piloter la
crise sanitaire en fonction du risque de
saturation hospitalière il peut sembler
surprenant que des lits soit massivement
fermé à l'hôpital public fin octobre
selon une étude menée par le président
du conseil scientifique un lit sur cinq
soit 20% seraient actuellement fermée au
sein de l'hôpital public chiffres que
vous contestez monsieur le ministre
considérant qu'il s'agirait plutôt de 5%
de lits de médecine temporairement
fermées avec des situations hétérogènes
sur le territoire
la fédération hospitalière de france
quand elle estime que le taux moyen de
lits fermés serait de 6% voilà pour les
chiffres comment expliquer une telle
discordance
en réalité le manque de personnel oblige
a laissé inoccupé bien plus que 6 % des
lits dans les faits ces lits sont bien
fermées mais seuls les lits fermés
administrativement
sont comptabilisées dans les chiffres
officiels à côté de ça l'absentéisme et
les démissions des professionnels santé
à l'hôpital augmente sérieusement en
raison de la dégradation progressive des
conditions de travail d'autre part les
ars accord des primes annuelles aux
directeurs d'hôpitaux qui sont
conditionnés par la réduction de la
masse salariale et des capacités des
hôpitaux ma question est double combien
de lits d'hôpitaux ont dû être
réellement fermés faute de personnel et
pourquoi maintenir ses prix mouillé au
réduction de la masse salariale et des
capacités hospitalières
la parole est commise solidarité et je
la chantais
mais salvatrice lassarade je ne sais que
vous répondre vous parlez de discordance
vous parlez de 10 15 ans entre des
chiffres énoncés excusez moi de vous le
dire des contrevérités et avec un
amalgame qui me paraît
probablement lié à une mauvaise
information je me permets de dire mais
le sujet est trop sérieux il n'y a pas
20 % de lits fermés dans les hôpitaux
dans notre pays il n'y a pas de
discordance entre deux méthodes non
madame la sénatrice il y a une méthode
qui consiste à compter les vis et une
méthode qui consiste à faire une
estimation au doigt mouillé et les six
nations doit mouiller si elles étaient
factuel et scientifique ça se saurait
vous avez la fhf la puissante et fhf qui
représente un tiers qui ai souri l'étude
basée sur un tiers du parc hospitalier
vous dit est un petit peu plus de
fermeture c'est aux alentours de 5 6%
moi j'ai une étude factuel chiffré
partir de 15000 chu que nous dit elle
cette étude à patrick un chu que nous
dit elle d'abord il ya plus de soignants
dans les hôpitaux à l'automne 2000 21
cas l'opic à l'automne 2010 9 nous
recrutons du personnel ensuite elle nous
dit qu'il ya à peu près 50 lits de
fermer en médecine supplémentaires qu'il
ya deux ans sur un parc de 12500 dit on
est assez loin et des 20% et des 5% même
la sénatrice ce qu'on voit c'est qu'à un
point d'absentéisme supplémentaires on
peut le comprendre après la crise qu
vide qui a marqué évidemment les esprits
et physique avec des congés qui sont
pris et c'est qu'ils sont récupérées
l'hôpital y tient madame la sénatrice on
a beau lui dire lui martelé qui ne tient
pas qui ne tient pas je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs quel est le sens de ce
discours 3 je suis pas sûr que ce soit
celui qui attend des soignants l'hôpital
tient bon et croyez moi nous faisons
l'essentiel même le maximum pour
attraper notamment des erreurs du passé
s'agissant de la formation des soignants
la formation des moyens de l'argent qui
est mis en place pour investir votre
votre collecte août à l'offre est dit
depuis sa nounou regretté nous regretté
que nous dépensions trop d'argent public
et là vous êtes en train de nous dire
qu'il faudrait encore plus d'argent
public alors même que nous dégageons 19
milliards d'euros pour investir pour
l'hôpital de capa discordance quant à
cette histoire de primes à damas d'imad
un mécène riespach dont le directeur des
hôpitaux sont des gens formidables qui
sont pas payés pour fermer des lits ou
pour virer du père elle s'est même c'est
même pas une erreur c'est une fête nous
je pense qu'elle est regrettable
[Applaudissements]
nous n'habitons pas le même pays
monsieur le ministre - zana de lits -
les soignants peuvent exercer leur
métier et plus nos malades en pâtissent
la parole est à notre collègue michel
qui avait pour le groupe union centriste
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues la france
est un grand pays maritime et nous avons
intérêt à préserver le potentiel qui en
découlent je ne pensions que les accords
du lié à la sortie de la grande-bretagne
de l'europe avait été bien négociés et
puis nous constatons aujourd'hui que
hélas 200 navires n'ont encore pas la
capacité d'aller pêcher dans les 6000
noter qu'autour de du continent bras de
britanniques et des îles anglo normandes
est ce normal des mesures de rétorsion
monsieur le premier ministre avait été
annoncée par le gouvernement la semaine
passée
aujourd'hui nous constatons que rien n'a
été réglé pouvez vous nous dire où est
ce qu'on en est précisément de la
situation des négociations
quelles mesures le gouvernement entend
prendre pour que ce dossier puisse enfin
être réglés et quelles sont les mesures
complémentaires que le gouvernement
pourrait prendre de façon à accompagner
les filières maritimes de la pêche et du
mariage notamment
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
surfeurs des corps francs charge des
affaires européennes monsieur clément
bonne
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison de souligner
la gravité cette situation nous
partageons la préoccupation et nous
agissons pour être très précis le
problème n'est pas l'accord qui a été
négocié jusqu'à tard dans l'année 2020
il comporte nous le savons un certain
nombre de compromis qui réduisent par
exemple les quotas de pêche qui sont
autorisés et qui amène à renégociation
de paramètres dans six ans mais
aujourd'hui le problème est que l'accord
n'est pas respecté et nous ne pouvons
pas à faire des compromis au delà de ce
qui a été négocié signés et ratifiés par
les parlements européen et britannique
ces derniers mois et donc depuis 10 mois
avec annick girardin sous l'autorité du
premier ministre nous travaillons avec
l'ensemble des élus avec les régions
concerner les hauts de france la
normandie et la bretagne avec les
professionnels surtout pour obtenir ces
licences de pêche nous les avons obtenus
intégralement pour la zone économique
exclusive et il en manque environ 200
vous avez raison d'eux rappelez ce
chiffre soit de licences qui sont
provisoires et que tu dois vous devenir
définitives soit de licence qui n'ont
pas du tout été octroyé nous continuons
à nous battre sans relâche avec annick
girardin pour ce faire c'est pourquoi
c'est pour cela que nous avons
indiqué il ya quelques jours que nous
étions en cause on est on prêt pardon à
prendre des mesures je crois que cette
fermeté supplémentaires a amené à une
nouvelle phase de dialogue avec les
britanniques j'ai reçu la semaine
dernière lors de frost qui s'occupe des
négociations sur le break 6 de jeu le
héros parlait hier il y a un jour d'hui
même une discussion sur jersey et sur
les deux points qui posent le plus
problème les petits navires ceux de
moins de 12 mètres car nous ne pouvons
pas fournir des preuves qui n'existent
pas liées à la géolocalisation en
particulier nous l'avons remis aux
britanniques et ce n'est pas prévu par
l'accord et les navires de remplacement
car les britanniques ajoute là aussi des
critères qui ne sont pas prévues par
l'accord je le redis ce que nous
demandons c'est simplement est
strictement l'application de l'accord
nous serons plus fermeté totale sur ce
point aussi ouvert que possible aussi
ferme que nécessaire et dans la tente
nous accompagnons évidemment le secteur
de la pêche avec un plan qui est le plus
important d'europe le 100 millions
d'euros pour l'ensemble de la filière
pour qu'elles fassent face à ces
difficultés temporaires à des
difficultés sur le mariage sur les
activités de pêche nous nous
mobiliserons toutes les sommes
nécessaires mais surtout ce que veulent
nos pêcheurs c'est reprendre leurs
activités économiques et c'est ça que
nous leur devons
oui nous partageons le l'objectif
effectivement que les patrons pêcheurs
puissent rapidement reprendre leur
travail mais cela fait onze mois que
cela dure et je pense qu'il est temps
que des solutions sont apportées la
france a voulu faire preuve de fermeté à
partir du début novembre je crois qu'il
convient effectivement de mettre en
oeuvre des mesures de rétorsion qui
permettent d'obtenir satisfaction car
sans cela on le voit bien plus le temps
passe et moi nous avons de perspective
d'obtenir des solutions positives pour
nos marins pêcheurs et les inquiétudes
ne cesse de monter sur les quais donc il
est important que des solutions systar
sont amenés il est important notamment
puisque les assises de la mer et des
produits de la mer vont se tenir à saint
pol de léon la semaine prochaine il est
important que pour ce moment là
il y a des réponses car sans cela il
risque d'y avoir un report de l'effort
de pêche sur d'autres jeunes et de
rendre d'autres zones de pêche prix g
préjudicier par la situation dont il
importe d'agir très rapidement
maintenant
merci
la parole et collègue stéphane sautarel
pour le groupe l'est républicain vous
avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues pas une
assemblée générale d'association des
maires de france vous avez participé à
celle des maires du cantal monsieur le
ministre y à peu pas un déplacement dans
une commune rurale mais aussi dans bien
des cas en milieu urbain ou en banlieue
sans que la question de la santé ne soit
abordée vous le savez tous mes chers
collègues au moment de l'examen du plfss
nous sommes nombreux issus de tous les
bancs avons alerté à vous faire des
propositions en matière de lutte active
contre les déserts médicaux la loi
relative à l'organisation et à la
transformation du système de santé de
2019 a notamment prévu à la demande du
sénat que pour les étudiants en dernière
année de troisième cycle celle ci soit
une année de pratique ambulatoire à
l'autonomie en priorité dans les zones
caractérisées par une offre de soins
insuffisante
le gouvernement n'a pas mis en oeuvre
cette disposition alors qu'il s'y était
engagé pourquoi
depuis le nombre de nos concitoyens qui
n'ont plus accès aux soins ne cesse de
croître il serait désormais selon la
drees plus de 4 millions et sans doute
bien davantage
la cour des comptes le préconisent les
maires le réclament les familles
l'exigent les patients en ont besoin
nord-est notre responsabilité politique
l'appel nous devons aller au-delà des
mesures incitatives qui ont leur sens
mais ne suffisent pas ne suffisent plus
dans la tente des effets du desserrement
du numerus clausus qu'il faut amplifier
nous devons agir
l'égal accès de tous aux soins ne
saurait attendre alors que chacun cotise
contribuer à une couverture de santé
dont trop sont exclues en particulier en
milieu rural
désormais même les professionnels de
santé réclament des mesures plus fortes
conventionnement sélectif stage
postdoctoral zones franches médical etc
que comptez vous faire monsieur le
ministre pour répondre aux attentes
légitimes de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le sénateur sautarel vous avez
raison souligné que dans un certain
nombre de territoires les déserts
médicaux progressent
vous avez d'ailleurs dit en attendant
que les effets de la suppression du
numerus clausus se fassent sentir ma
première et ma première réponse la
première réponse est de dire si le
numerus clausus avait été supprimé il ya
dix ans factuellement aujourd'hui il y
aurait dix à quinze mille médecins de
plus sur les territoires on ne parlerait
pas de déserts médicaux et la ceni aux
us n'a pas été supprimée ya dix ans ni à
15 ans il ya vingt ans on m'a donné
quand on coupe un robinet on peut pas
regarder le lavabo seriez pas d'eau qui
tombent c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé avec la médecine donc maintenant
vous faites le constat des dégâts qui
ont été provoqués par la police les
politiques du passé c'est factuel de
l'année nous avons supprimé le numerus
clausus est par ailleurs nous
développons les communautés
professionnelles des territoires de
santé nombre de sénateurs que j'ai vu
dans les territoires sont satisfaites cc
pts pour améliorer l'accès coordonnées
nous débattons en ce moment même le
plfss avec un certain nombre de
dispositions prévues par le gouvernement
pour faciliter l'accès des français aux
soins optiques par exemple ou un accès
direct à certaines professions et je
m'étonne que nombre de sénateurs ici
présent très sensibilisé je le sais a la
cote des déserts médicaux déposé un
amendement visant à supprimer toutes
dispositions permettant de favoriser les
coopérations interprofessionnelles et
donc de rendre moins dépendant les
français à l'accès direct aux médecins
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de médecins dans les
territoires concernés vous avez
l'occasion la d'envoyer un autre signal
à la population que celui qui consiste à
rester dans une forme de conservatisme
qui ne facilite pas l'accès aux soins
nous déployons aussi la télémédecine qui
est un élément important nous
développons les services d'accès aux
soins dans les territoires ça aussi
c'est un élément qui est important
monsieur le sénateur donc nous
progressons nous mettons en place toutes
les solutions partout où elles peuvent
exister ensuite vous allez dire c'est
une pirouette mais souvent les gens sont
d'accord souvent les gens sont d'accord
les parlementaires sont d'accord pour
qu'on empêche les médecins de
s'installer dans certains endroits mais
j'ai jamais encore trouver un
parlementaire d'hier l'assemblée
nationale ni au sénat qui considère que
dans le territoire qu'il représente il y
aurait suffisamment de médecins pour
qu'on empêche de s'installer pourquoi
parce que la pénurie est globale et si
je me trompe venait me voir et on nous
regarderons la situation ensemble
je saute aurel
monsieur le ministre la pénurie est
peut-être global mais la responsabilité
d'aujourd'hui et d'agir une loi a été
adoptée en 2019 elle n'est pas appliquée
d'autres mesures peuvent intervenir
faute de quoi il y aura un réel problème
d'accès aux soins à nos concitoyens et
la responsabilité c'est le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui qu'il apportera
[Applaudissements]
paroles et ça notre collègue jean
jacques michau pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et république vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues personne ici ne
méconnaît le fait déplorable est
insupportable que bon nombre
d'agriculteurs dans notre pays ne vive
pas de la rémunération de la vente de
leur production l'échec de la loi
égalise ainsi que les timides avancées
de la loi visant à protéger la
rémunération des agriculteurs des ti et
galim deux n'auront qu'un effet limité
sur le revenu des agriculteurs
depuis de nombreuses années c'est grâce
à la pac que ces agriculteurs vivent ou
plutôt survivent ce sens ces aides qui
sont le vrai revenu des agriculteurs qui
leur permettent de boucler leurs fins de
mois et de faire face à leurs
obligations en conséquence quand ces
aides ne sont pas versées aux dates
prévues les agriculteurs doivent
négocier des emprunts auprès des banques
pour combler leurs besoins de trésorerie
sinon c'est notamment le cas au moment
où je vous parle car les aides qui
devait être versée au 15 octobre dans
mon département l'ariège mais aussi dans
bien d'autres et notamment en occitanie
n'ont pas encore été versées vos
services monsieur le ministre annonce
qu'elle ne le seront pas avant le 15
décembre deux mois deux mois sans aide
et encore si ces promesses peuvent être
tenus alors monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues doit-on incriminé
l'europe pour ses retards
comme on a si souvent tendance à le
faire parfois à raison dans le cas
d'espèce ce n'est pas bruxelles qui est
en cause l'argent est bien disponible
mais pour qu'ils soient versées aux
agriculteurs il faut que l'état français
et réaliser les contrôles de leur
exploitation en s'agissant d'argent
public personne ici ne remette en cause
la tenue de ces contrôles qui vérifie la
bonne conformité des productions
agricoles ce que je déplore et qui est
inadmissible c'est que l'administration
française n'est pas les moyens
d'effectuer ses contrôles dans les bacs
délai imparti pour que les agriculteurs
reçoivent les aides nécessaires à leur
survie aux dates que vous aviez annoncé
alors monsieur le ministre qu'allez vous
faire pour que nos agriculteurs
reçoivent leur prime le plus rapidement
possible je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur normandie vous
avez la parole merci beaucoup monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur michôd d'abord vous dire qu'à
la fin des fins défunt le plus important
c'est de faire en sorte que nos
agriculteurs vivent de la juste
rémunération est pas d aide et je crois
pouvoir dire que les avancées que nous
avons fait voter ici à l'unanimité au
sénat de la loi et galim 2 va dans le
bon sens le deuxième élément monsieur le
sénateur c'est qu'effectivement les
aides de la pac reste très importante
elle reste d'autant plus importante que
la bataille sur la rémunération de n'est
pas encore gagné et qu'on s'y emploie
mais monsieur le sénateur
votre question ne reflètent en aucun cas
la réalité et je dois vous dire que pour
un représentant de l'ancienne majorité
je trouve ça plus que fort de café alors
monsieur le sénateur et c'est vérifiable
partout je vais vous donner les vrais
chiffres dans le département de l'ariège
au 19 octobre
95 % des bénéficiaires ont eu les
avances de paiements de la pac sur 1800
dossier il y avait au 19 octobre 83
dossier qui n'avait pas bénéficié d
avance pour deux raisons soit parce
qu'il y à des contrôles en cours comme
il y en a dans tous les départements
soit parce que du fait des dérogations
ou est 6e ceux qui sont au fait de ce
sujet le voit bien il y à un décalage et
monsieur le sénateur je vais vous donner
les chiffres au niveau national en 2020
en 2020
99 7 % des paiements de la pac ont été
faits dans les délais en 2017 le chiffre
était à
4,45 % en 2015 il était à 0% alors ses
leçons de morale en ne donnant pas les
vrais chiffres c'est insupportable
un
autre collègue laure darcos pour le
groupe les résultats
merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à nouveau à
monsieur le ministre des solidarités de
la santé monsieur le ministre l'hôpital
public va mal et les soignants sont au
bord de la crise de nerfs quand le
gouvernement communique sur les
milliards d'euros mobilisés dans le
cadre de figures de la santé les
services sur le terrain peine à assurer
leurs missions auprès des patients
remise en cause des vocations
multiplication des burn out pénurie des
soignants difficultés de recrutement
fermetures de lits l'hôpital fait face à
des difficultés sans fin dans le
prolongement de la crise de lakovic 19
et comme vous avez dit tout à l'heure à
ma collègue qu'elle faisait des
amalgames je vais vous donner un exemple
précis et services de pédiatrie en
particulier sont en situation de tension
extrême et doivent aujourd'hui traiter
les conséquences de l'épidémie de la
santé sur la santé des adolescents dans
un contexte de saturation totale des
structures b de pédopsychiatrie régional
et doivent aussi composer avec un départ
massif des pédiatres vers le secteur
privé où ces professionnels échappe aux
contraintes toujours plus lourd de la
permanence des soins à titre d'exemple
service de pédiatrie de l'hôpital
d'orsay dans mon département a perdu 4 2
6 et 6 pédiatre ce qui a conduit à la
fermeture de 12 lits qui manque
cruellement la pénurie de personnels non
médicaux entraîne quant à elle le gel
des lits de pédiatrie et de néonatalogie
dans tous les hôpitaux comme par exemple
à longjumeau enfin pour ajouter à cette
situation désespérante une survenue
précoce de l'épidémie de bronchiolite
génère un nombre record de consultations
dans les services hospitaliers dans ce
contexte se pose donc la question
cruciale de la compensation d'extrême
pénibilité des gardes de nuit pour les
médecins actuellement de moins de 18
euros bruts par heure nous savons
qu'elle se traduit par des départs multi
de l'hôpital public en particulier dans
les secteurs de musiciens pas d'un
calcul horaire du temps de travail des
médecins comme la pédiatrie et la
gynécologie obstétrique il s'agit d'un
angle mort du ségur monsieur le ministre
vous avez vous même reconnu la situation
de tension dans les services d'urgences
de pédiatrie dans les maternités lors de
votre présence au salon de la fédération
hospitalière de france comptez-vous
prendre une initiative forte en la
matière pour éviter une catastrophe
annoncée
pour vous répondre la parole et kobe
solidarité de la santé je lui niche
à nouveau madame la sénatrice sans nier
les tensions qui peuvent exister
d'ailleurs qu'on retrouve en chaque
année vernal et automnale et qu'on
retrouve un peu plus de façon un peu
plus exacerbée un peu plus exacerbée
cette année après dix-huit mois de lutte
effrénée contre le contre la crise du
coded entre la colline je ne dis donc
pas les difficultés attention aux
discours alarmistes qui peuvent
provoquer sur le terrain un effet qui
n'est certainement pas recherché mais
qui brille est un tendre a créé des
tensions du découragement là où au
contraire je crois vraiment que les
soignants aux besoins de nos
encouragements je sais c'est pas votre
démarche mada sénatrice et je respecte
votre question d'abord vous dites oh non
il ya moins en moins de pédiatres oui ya
de moins en moins de médecins et oui et
ça va encore durer pendant un tout petit
peu de temps parce que c'est des
conséquences du numerus clausus je vois
à nouveau je vous renvoie madame la
sénatrice au constat que vous et dont
vous et moi souffrons aujourd'hui et
dont tous les français souffrent mais
c'est un fait il faut dix ans pour
former un médecin je ne peux pas en
claquant des doigts en forme et 15000
est dit on va mettre des pédales partout
donc la conséquence de la maîtrise mal
mais dit que la mauvaise maîtrise
médicalisée pendant près de 50 ans dans
notre pays c'est qu'on manque
aujourd'hui de médecins j'en fais le
constat avec vous je le déplore mais
nous avons pris la seule décision qui
était rival qui vaille c'est à dire la
suppression du numerus clausus nous
formons plus de 2000 médecins
supplémentaires cette année que dans
quinquennat précédent ensuite il ya une
charge de travail importante en
pédiatrie qui est lié à l'activité de
pédopsychiatrie ce que vous avez
souligné et c'est une croissance de
l'acquitter pédopsychiatrique on avait
commencé à constater avant la crise qu
vide et qui se poursuivra qui s'accentue
de fait jusqu à 30% des dites pédiatrie
générale sont occupés par des enfants
qui relève de la pédopsychiatrie et là
aussi on a une vraie pénurie médicale en
pédopsychiatrie et là aussi on est
déterminé en forme et bien davantage
dans les années à venir
la période hivernale a commencé fort
avec une bronchiolite qui est arrivée
par anticipation au moins deux à trois
semaines plus tôt que les années
précédentes il y en a pas eu
il y avait peut-être un meilleur respect
des gestes barrières du coup il ya moins
d'immunité conférer est acquise par les
enfants ce qui provoque une épidémie
assez violente en revanche madame la
sénatrice sur les i nostri toutes les
enquêtes dont je dispose bon il ya
autant de lits d'obstétrique ouvert dans
notre pays qu'à la même période en 2010
9 par ailleurs l'activité de chirurgie y
compris une chirurgie pédiatrique et
plus importante cette année dans le
secteur privé par exemple qu'elle ne
l'était il ya deux ans donc à des
secteurs en tension dans les secteurs
d'urgence notamment la pédiatrie fait
face à une très forte demande et nous
sommes partout loi il le faut où il faut
être au contact des hôpitaux pour les
aider à tenir dans la période contre une
situation de tension même des pages
générales et l'hôpital n'est pas en
train de craquer madame sénatrice la
parole et l autre collègue nadia sulu
pour le groupe de lino fortune
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse encore
une au ministre de la santé monsieur le
ministre les services d'urgence
fonctionne tant bien que mal désormais
certains vont même jusqu'à fermer la
pénurie dure gentil c'est telles qu'un
système mercantile s'est mise en place
siphonnant les moyens financiers des
hôpitaux et compromettant la prise en
charge des patients c'est terriblement /
g n et de nombreux dans de nombreux
départements les citoyens ont peur et se
sentent abandonnés presque partout vous
l'avez dit on manque cruellement de
médecins prime pas primes bonus fiscaux
aide à l'installation pour trouver ces
perles rares que sont les médecins c'est
un vaste mercato qui s'est mis en place
les élus sont prêts à toutes les
compromissions pour chiper celui de
leurs voisins mais ce marchés malsains
et les surenchères financière ne règle
rien bien au contraire et c'est ce que
l'on constate aujourd'hui
depuis plus de dix ans on nous dit
chaque année qu'il suffit d'attendre un
peu pour que les choses s'arrangent mais
c'est de pire en pire alors ma question
est simple monsieur le ministre comme
aujourd'hui nous donnons nous enfin les
moyens y compris en terme de logistique
d'enseignants de capacité d'accueil en
stage d'encadrement des internes de
qualité de formation de faire coïncider
l'offre et la demande de soins et à
quelle échéance vous nous avez évoquer
monsieur le ministre le numerus clausus
mais vous savez bien que c'est en terme
de temps médical qu'il faut raisonner je
voudrais être certaine que les
modélisations du ministère intègre les
changements de modes d'exercice le
salariat la féminisation de la
profession le nombre de médecins et
d'étudiants qui abandonne soit leur
formation sera leur profession et
d'autre part le vieillissement de la
population et les besoins croissants à
quel niveau placez-vous le curseur pour
les urgentistes mais aussi les médecins
de ville et dans toutes les spécialités
pour que partout dans le pays les
français enfin la garantie de trouver un
médecin quand ils en ont besoin jour
merci pour vos réponses la parole est à
mme schmid laissant la solidarité
descente est à nouveau madame la
sénatrice autre question est
parfaitement pertinente et vous en fait
le diagnostic partagé le numerus clausus
a entraîné une pénurie globale de
médecins dans le pays mais je sais pas
ce qui vous est très en vue d'intéresser
les sénateurs cc c'est un constat je le
redis si vous ne former plus de médecins
vingt ans plus tard il ya plus de
médecins et celles et ceux qui ont
décidé de ne pas former de médecins
pendant 40 ans ne peuvent pas nous
regarder nous qui avons enfin desserrer
l'étau supprimant le numerus clausus en
nous reprochant le manque de médecins
tigha pas pardonnez moi il n'y a pas un
français qui rentrent dans ce piège les
gens parfaitement compris et nous et
d'ailleurs vous avez été un certain
nombre à le déplorer avec nous et vous
avez été un certain nombre à voter cette
disposition mais c'est la triste
néanmoins nous faisons face nous faisons
face à cette situation de pénurie la
pénurie est l'entrée des dégâts plus
importants médecine d'urgence parce
qu'en plus la médecine d'urgence et une
médecine qui s'inscrit pas dans la durée
avec de l'usure de l'épuisement qu'on
peut comprendre et les ententistes qui
vont de temps en temps faire une autre
forme de médecine parce qu'ils sont
fatigués cet exercice qui accroît les
effets de la pénurie mais le problème de
base c'est le même si on avait dit
l'urgentiste de plus dans ce pays on se
poserait pas la question la pénurie si
on avait vingt mille médecins
généralistes le plus en ce pays on se
poserait pas la question des déserts
médicaux comme il ya cette pénurie
qu'est ce que nous proposons qu'est ce
que nous proposons au delà du
regroupement avec des médecins et des
paramédicaux les fameuses c'est pts au
delà la participation de la ville et
l'hôpital à la permanence des soins à
travers le service de soins non
programmés et le saas nous proposons de
permettre à des professionnels de santé
non mais dites qui dans quasiment tous
les pays qui nous entourent sont
capables d'effectuer et ont des
reconnaissances de compétences pour des
actes qui aujourd'hui ne relèvent que
des médecins on propose de permettre à
ces paramédicaux dans des conditions
sécurisées de les exercer qu'est ce que
je note toutes les propositions du
gouvernement en la matière dans le cas
du plfss font l'objet d'au moins 1 à 10
amendements de suppression venant de la
plupart des banques de cet hémicycle
aidez nous madame la sénatrice aidez
nous apporter ce discours qui est un
discours concret ce n'est pas de votre
faute à vous sinon on n'a plus de
médecin notre pays c'est certainement
pas de la mienne non plus qu il fut
battu contenu mais le squeeze pendant
des années mais face à ce constat ne
renouvelant pas les échecs allons de
l'avant
alain leleu vous vous avez quelque chose
on
monsieur le ministre j'ai demandé
excusez moi quand quand est-ce qu'on
commence à compter de 2017 2021 fait
2010 est plus 10 en 2021 puce disant je
sais pas si vous concours t est encore
là dans dix ans mais ça aurait été bien
qu'on puisse fêter ça ensemble je
remercie le che et la parole est à notre
collègue esther benbassa
pour les réunions des sénateurs de
fillon sur la lise luka un gros coup la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le 4 novembre un bilan est
retrouvé mort sur une plage de wissant
dans le pas de calais deux autres le
même jour en hypothermie sont
transportés à l'hôpital le même jour
interel en percuter accidentellement
4 qui circulent sur les voies faisant un
mort et un blessé en urgence absolue la
liste est hélas longue de ces tragédies
ils sont arrivés au péril de leur vie en
france illizi trouve l'amant plutôt que
l'accueil ils veulent gagner la
grande-bretagne pour s'y construire un
avenir plus décent on les en empêche
hilaire en attendant dans les rues de
calais
le pl est le plein de philippe de mester
en fait 25 jours de grève de la faim
deux autres personnes ludovic hole ben
naïs google l'ont accompagné dans cette
action et poursuivent leur grève et ce
pour dénoncer la situation des quelques
1500 migrants présenta que présent à
calais rien je me suis rendu avec mon
cabinet pour les voir et les entendre
ainsi que les associations depuis le 27
octobre un médiateur choisi par le
gouvernement
didier leschi directeur de l'office
tente de trouver un compromis rien de
nouveau rien de concret n'est sorti de
ces négociations les grands et
associations attendent moratoire sur les
évacuations pour l'hiver que comptez
vous faire monsieur le ministre n'aimant
détresse urgence font-ils partie de
votre vocabulaire la république at elle
oui ou non un devoir de fraternité à
l'égard de jean qui avant d'être
clandestins sont nos semblables des
humains mais pour vous répondra parole à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur je
lui nistre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice sa république depuis longtemps
depuis longtemps à son devoir de
fraternité depuis le 1er janvier ses
12000 personnes que l'argent public que
la république a relogé alors que très
grande partie vous le savez d'entre eux
sont irriguées sur le territoire
national tous les jours nous distribuons
l'état deux mille deux cents repas à
calais pour 4 millions d'euros d'argent
public tous les jours nous intervenons
madame pour pouvoir sauver des migrants
qui essaient de traverser la manche sur
un mot que vous n'avez pas prononcé une
seule fois ce qui montre à mon avis le
petit biais de penser les passeurs
madame ce sont des criminels qui
utilisent des femmes des enfants des
hommes qu'ils leur font payer beaucoup
d'argent pour les traversées de l'autre
côté de la manche la province en leur
promettant l' eldorado alors qu'il y à
de très nombreux enfants de très
nombreuses femmes de très nombreux
hommes qui meurent qui meurt dans la
manche parce que nous sommes mal
heureusement trop naïf avec des discours
comme les vôtres en laissant des
criminels que sont des passeurs
exploiter la misère humaine si nous
laissons de nouveau la jungle
s'installer à qu'elle est non seulement
nous mettrons des conditions absolument
indigne pour les migrants et pour les
riverains de calais par exemple mais
surtout nous mettrons sous la main de
criminels de criminels des gens qui
veulent passer de l'autre côté de la
manche dans des conditions absolument
inacceptable madame 70% des migrants qui
sont à calais aujourd'hui viennent de
belgique ou d'allemagne
la france parce qu'elle a une position
géographique est à la fois fraternelle
est aussi ferme et luttent contre des
criminels que sont des passeurs alors
aujourd'hui oui bien sûr nous
accompagnons les migros c'est la france
qui subventionnait association c'est la
france qui paye les repas c'est la
france qui permet à des policiers des
gendarmes tous les jours on risque de
leurs vies de sauvées des migrants en
mer mais nous ne souhaitons pas un seul
instant encourager des criminels que
sont des passeurs rien pour la bonne
conscience
mais
[Musique]
nous avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité
il vous restait quelques secondes non
s'cusez moi
au nom des passeurs ça a toujours été
comme ça dans les soirs alors c'est pas
les pas seul qu'il faut
accuser ils voient accusés mais monsieur
il faudra user
il fait accuser
voix on peut quand même revoir n'est ce
pas les bons écoutez on ne peut pas
parler donc le débat n'est pas possible
merci excusez moi
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les miss merci les prochaines
questions rôle yeux le 17 novembre
la science va être suspendu et reprise à
16h35 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale pour 2022 c'est quand ses juges
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du sénat au gouvernement que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur public sénat place
maintenant aux réactions après cette
séance il va tout de suite aller en
salle des conférences du sénat où un
autre journaliste yves jourdain est avec
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
l'est républicain ville oui bruno
retailleau bonjour dont j'ai rasé d'être
avec nous allocution d'emmanuel macro
hier j'imagine que vous l'avez suivi
vous avez vu un président déjà en
campagne ou hier au bob est sûre il
suffisait de le voir de l'écouter il a
pris en quelque sorte les français entre
est parce que les français écoutait